thank you everyone for coming today as
jeff mentioned this is my phd defense so
i'll be presenting my thesis work
entitled insights from patient authored
text from close reading to automated
extraction and i'll start by answering
the question that is probably on
everybody's mind what is patient author
text and why do we care about it and
then i'll state the contributions of our
work and describe our data and
methodological process having
established these preliminaries i'll
present our first project a depth in
which we address the problem of
identifying medical terms in pad
and i'll then spend the majority of my
time talking about our work on forum 77
in which we focus specifically on pat
related to the topic of substance abuse
i'll go through three projects called
drugs of choice purpose and phases of
addiction
and finally i'll offer some concluding
thoughts present key areas for future
work and take questions
so when the internet became commercially
available in the mid 90s it
revolutionized the way in which we
interact with health data
firstly it made this information more
available to people
it also promoted your ever your everyday
health information consumer to a health
information contributor and thirdly it
facilitated connections between people
with shared interests and so using the
internet as a health resource is
extremely popular and remains so was
well has always been extremely popular
and remains so today so in 2002
2012 the pew health online survey
estimated that some 72 percent of
american adults go online to seek health
information and that of these 17 16 to
18 percent of them specifically seek out
other people who share their health
concerns
now that might not sound like a lot but
if we extrapolate from the census
bureau's population estimate for the
united states this comprises some 50 to
57 million people and the result of this
is that users are online generating
massive quantities of what we call
patient authored text
which is essentially any medical text
that's authored by a non-medical expert
a main source of patient author texts
are online health communities which are
just online discussion boards centered
around a particular medical topic
probably everyone in this room has
consumed data from an online health
community even if you've not contributed
to one and this is the type of data we
use in our work
other sources of pat include personal
blogs email
search logs and social media data such
as facebook and twitter
so that's all well and good but what
actually goes into creating pat
this here is a sample post from forum 77
that helps community for addiction this
user is taping tapering off methadone
and he wants some advice on managing his
withdrawal symptoms and at a glance we
can tell that there's quite a bit of
information here there's a medical
history
there's a treatment plan
there's a detailed record of his
symptoms including waves of depression
bad thoughts anger finding it hard to
move and then there's a request for
advice on a specific symptom that's
troubling him
these are fairly typical components of
pat others might include users
performing drug comparisons
diagnoses or
comparing medical test results
so overall in the process of creating
pat users are documenting medical data
they're making sense of it they're
prioritizing it they're synthesizing it
and they're doing this in order to solve
problems that are relevant to them
and this is time intensive work
performed by highly motivated agents and
together this work culminates in a
unique record of patients behavior
outside of the clinical environment
this is especially true in the cases of
embarrassing or stigmatized conditions
such as hepatitis c or addiction because
prior work actually shows that such
people are more likely to seek health
information online and in some cases
less likely to seek formal medical
attention
so in concert pat comprises a valuable
and in many cases unique medical data
set it's also abundant and readily
available but in spite of this attempts
to leverage pat to gain medically
relevant insights have been limited and
there are a couple of reasons for this
the first is that while pat is rich with
valuable data it's extremely noisy
at the text level we have misspellings
inconsistent grammar at the user level
we have inconsistent participation we
have data being filtered through a human
who is only including the parts that she
thinks are relevant and this person has
some unknown level of medical expertise
and command over medical jargon
second there's the dearth of existing
extracting tools
extraction tools for analyzing pat so
for example as you'll see when i discuss
adept it's difficult to even extract the
medically relevant terms out of pat
this makes it hard to explore pat
corporate let alone
test hypotheses on them
and finally the question of whether pat
actually supports a research question or
not is not obvious and it depends very
deeply on the user's reason for
authoring the text in the first place so
for example it's been shown that search
logs are a good data set to try to mine
to try to predict flu epidemic outbreaks
from because people are motivated to
google for those their symptoms when
they get sick however it would be
unlikely that we could mine
the optimal dosage of paracetamol from
twitter because people aren't posting on
twitter the dosage of paracetamol that
they use
so determining what data pad encodes and
how it's encoded is a separate challenge
in and of itself
in our work we address these challenges
in a couple of ways so to handle
noisiness we obviously focus on entity
resolution and text processing but at
the human level
we leverage automated extraction to get
large volumes of data this enables us to
aggregate over many people which can
compensate for individual noisiness
to address the dearth of existing tools
we follow a specific methodological
framework that results in automatic
classifiers which we share to support
future work
and finally to address the question of
research support we both collaborated
closely with an addiction specialist
anna lemke
and utilized close readings over our
source text in order to develop detailed
schema describing the content of the
data
we call these thematic analysis and this
is actually a branch of prior work and
the goal of a thematic analysis is
essentially to do a qualitative analysis
over text to get a deep understanding of
its content and structure so for example
murnanen counts analyze
with the twitter feed of people who are
attempting smoking cessation in order to
determine whether their behavior changes
before and after the event it's rare
however to see thematic analyses
leveraged to the point of automatic
extraction
usually the data is hand labeled
on the other end of the spectrum falls
work on pharmacovigilance and syndromic
surveillance in which
people mind pat in order to detect to
detect adverse medical events in real
time so the example that people would be
most familiar with is google flu where
uh
the tool tries to predict flu outbreaks
uh before they ahead of the cdc data
another category is entity extraction
which falls under the purview of nlp and
machine learning and this the goal in
here is to identify particular entities
in text so for example in collaborative
work with stoneal gupta and chris
we use flexible pattern matching to
identify drugs and treatments and
symptoms and conditions in med help text
and finally some prior work does combine
thematic analysis with large-scale
investigations most notably that by
mumunda chowdhury who analyzes
postpartum depression as it manifests on
users facebook and twitter feeds
now work on adept in drugs of choice
falls closer to the entity extraction
and syndromic surveillance side of
things and our work on phases of
addiction and purpose built on prior
work
and literature from thematic analyses
automated extractions and large-scale
analyses
and we make two primary contributions
first we develop methods for
automatically extracting a variety of
medically relevant texts from data from
pat
and second we derive novel insights from
these extracted data what sorts of
insights well often they're medically
relevant and they tell us something new
about a condition we didn't know a lot
about but they can also be used to
inform interface design or
further
hci or cscw
research and in this work we focus
specifically on the topic of addiction
for reasons i'll get into after i talk
about the adopt project
we use data from the website med help
which comprises about 200 online health
community communities each focused on a
specific health topic
and for the general med health data set
we have about three and a half years of
discussion data
and for our work on addiction we use
forum 77 which is med helps
forum on addiction and substance abuse
this is the largest community on med
health
and we have seven years worth of
discussion data comprised comprising
eighty thousand threads
about three quarters of a million posts
authored by some fifty thousand unique
users
so just to get us on the same page about
what these data actually look like
on the left here we have a number of
names of online health communities each
community dedicated to a specific
medical topic if you look inside a
community you'll see that it's composed
of a collection of threads or
discussions
and if you looked into a discussion you
would see that it's comprised of an
initiating post
in which a user poses a question or a
comment to the community and a
collection of response posts in which
other people respond to the initiator
and note that the initiator can also
respond to the thread later on we call
this a self-response and so we'll use
these terms initiating post
self-response and response posts towards
the end of the talk in our work on phase
and what do we do with this data
we use a similar methodological
framework throughout our work starting
with patient author text a close reading
gives insight into what kind of data pat
encodes and how it encodes it this gives
us a schema over the content now
sometimes the schema can just be
internalized knowledge and sometimes the
schema is a contribution in and of
itself if it's illuminating a poorly
understood area
once we have a schema over the content
we can use it to acquire human annotated
data
depending on the complexity of the
schema this might be an iterative stage
in which we use our human labels to
revise the schema
but once we're satisfied with our data
annotation we then use it to train
statistical classifiers to automatically
label large quantities of data
again this can be an iterative process
where we tune our classifier where we
tune out features in order to improve
classifier performance
once we're satisfied we can then apply
our classifiers to large quantity of pat
to get machine labeled data
and then after any required
post-processing we analyze the extracted
data in order to derive insights
so i'm now going to present our work on
adept
this work was motivated by what seemed
to be a simple problem to us when we set
out
given some patient author text like this
how do we extract the terms that are
medically relevant for example how do we
go from this text
to this where we've highlighted the
terms that are medically relevant in
green
like many before us we turn to the most
obvious solutions which are well-known
ontology-based tools meta-map and the
open biomedical annotator ontologies are
curated collections of vocabularies with
hierarchical relationships between the
terms so
using these tools gives you very nice
entity resolution unfortunately however
they perform very poorly on pat and it's
not just us who found this
the next obvious solution is to turn to
a statistical based tagger
and train a classifier
to specifically extract entities
relevant to your task now
these models have very good performance
but can require large volumes of
training data this can be a problem
especially when you need medical experts
to annotate your data because that's
both costly and time-consuming however
given that our data is authored by
non-medical experts in the first place
we hypothesized that we might be able to
crowdsource this task
so we post two hypotheses in this work
first that a crowd can
that a crowd of non-experts can replace
medical experts at the pat medical term
identification task and second the
classifiers trained on this data would
outperform the state-of-the-art tools
meta map and oba
so to test our first hypothesis we first
needed to design a crowdsourcing task
and our original prompt which we ran
through amazon mechanical turk was to
just copy paste terms that you find
medically relevant into the text box
below and we got some pretty bad results
the biggest problem was context so
users would include terms that could be
medically relevant in some context but
weren't in the sentence so in this
sentence anxiety is not a user symptom
she's talking about a social phenomenon
about talking to other people on the
forum
a mission people just wouldn't do the
task
numerical inclusion and concept
granularity were very inconsistent so
some people would include drug dosages
some people would include the term low
in low blood sugar and others wouldn't
and then repetition users would
typically tag only one instance of a
word in a sentence even if it appeared
multiple times
so we found that changing the prompt to
ask users to include terms that they
found that they thought a doctor would
find medically relevant actually helped
the problem of context a great deal we
think this is because it made the task
seem less subjective than it actually
was
we tried to address the issue of
omission by getting them to put n a into
the text box anyway
but this is still easier than copy
pasting the terms this didn't help much
however
when we told the turkers that we would
reject their answers if they didn't
match other turker's answers uh they
stopped admitting they stopped emitting
things and the results became quite
consistent
we dealt with numerical inclusion and
concept granularity through explicit
examples and repetition through
post-processing simply propagating the
label of medically relevant to all other
identical terms in the sentence
so having designed this task
we next wanted to test the crowd's
performance against medical experts we
took a sample of a thousand sentences
from rent from midhelp
and created a gold standard by getting
three registered nurses to label each
sentence we took majority vote for
turkey for token inclusion
and then had five turkers label each
sentence and compared their performance
across different voting thresholds to
the nurses
we found that turkish perform well
against the gold standard when we use a
corroborative voting policy which
requires at least two terms to be to two
votes for a term to be labeled as
medically relevant and so we conclude
that a crowd of medical experts is a
sufficient replacement
um for for medical experts in the pat
term identification task
next we train a classifier that we call
adept to automatically identify
medically relevant terms
we choose adept to be a conditional
random field model or crf because crfs
are especially appropriate for
sequence-based and context-sensitive
tasks
basically given an item in a sequence a
crf can take into consideration the
items that appear before and after that
item in order to determine whether it
belongs to a specific entity class or
not for example
in these two sentences the word tired
occurs in both sentences but in the
first one it's not a symptom whereas in
the second one it is
a context-sensitive model is able to
determine that the first sentence that
the first instance of tired is not is
not medically relevant while the second
one is and this is actually our
classifier output by the way
we train adept on 10 000 crowd labeled
sentences and then evaluate its
performance
so performance on cross validation is
good and holds to the gold standard
which was labeled by the by the nurses
and then we also compare it against an
independent gold standard which we
source from cure together
which is a different online health
community
and again the adept performance holds
over this data set and also notable is
the fact that it dramatically
outperforms the other tools meta map
and the oba
so we can see how a depth performs on
our original prompt green are the terms
that it got correct it incorrectly
omitted night sweats night in the term
night sweats and nightmares and it
included some terms erroneously such as
sleeping
and food but this last instance actually
starts to highlight the ambiguity of
this task food in this case could be
used as a treatment for this guy's
withdrawal symptoms to make him feel
better
we can look at adept's mistakes more
generally to get insight into what it's
getting wrong and right so this chart
logs term frequency against
classification accuracy in our corpus
and blue dots show terms that were
misclassified at least once the size of
the dot represents the number of terms
so for example this bottom left-hand
blue dot here shows that about 500 terms
were never correctly classified and
these appeared
only once in the test corpus
so unsurprisingly we see that items that
occur less frequently are more likely to
be incorrectly classified
so we might ameliorate some of these
problems by adding additional training
data
and it remains to look at the terms that
are commonly or ambiguously classified
in looking at these no obvious patterns
emerge save from the exception that a
lot of them were what we call generic
terms so terms like doctor doctors
appointment these are all terms that are
definitely medical but they contain very
little information and it turns out that
human annotators struggle with whether
they should include these sorts of terms
as well
so we show that a crowd of non-experts
can replace medical experts at this task
and this gets us cheap and scalable data
annotation but can we apply this to
other sorts of entities
so we explored this in two projects we
tried we tried to use a similar prompts
to get turkish to identify drugs and
treatments in the same sort of text and
also symptoms or conditions
in the same sort of texts
and we got extremely poor results they
were inconsistent and they were
incorrect and sometimes the turkers
actually defaulted to just including any
medically relevant term
at all
we thought about why this was and the
task is actually quite different from
the adept task it's a lot more
subjective so for example the term
wheelchair that's medically relevant but
is it a treatment
and there's also this sort of scoping
issue so symptom descriptions tend to
span long phrases so a sharp pain on the
left side of my back spreading down to
my thigh should you include that entire
phrase as a symptom or should you break
it down into smaller components
so it turned out that this is quite a
different task and
could we actually crowdsource this well
probably i think so but we would need to
design the task specifically and it
became apparent that there's a trade-off
between the cost of designing this task
and the cost of just labeling the data
ourselves
in our future projects we don't have we
don't deal with big enough data sets
that we couldn't without we can't label
it ourselves
but this remains an important area for
future work especially when you need
large quantities of label data or when
you need to rapidly replicate your data
annotation
so
our crowdsourcing method gives us cheap
and scalable data but there's a
trade-off between designing the task and
labeling the data ourselves and finally
our classifiers trained on the crowd
label data did outperform state of the
state-of-the-art tools quite
dramatically
i won't go into the applications of
adept in the interest of time but if you
apply adept to a pat corpus what you get
is several medically relevant terms you
can do frequency and co-occurrence
analyses over these terms to get a
bird's-eye view over the over the
corpus's content as well as the
structure within it
in the case of adept
our close reading and content schema
involved the iterative design of a
crowdsourcing task for medical term
annotation
we found that the crowd can indeed be
used to annotate these data and that we
were able to train a conditional random
field classifier on this crowd label
data to outperform existing tools
finally we can apply the classifier to
get a quick overview of a pat corpus
next i'm going to move on to our work on
forum 77 but before i talk about our
first project drugs of choice i'm going
to give a brief inter overview of why we
want to look at addiction in the first
place so why addiction
well drug and alcohol use disorders
present one of the most pressing public
health issues of the day and of
particular concern
is the escalating misuse of prescription
drugs so in 2008 more than 36 000 deaths
were due to overdoses of prescription
drugs sorry were due to drug overdoses
and of these those due to prescription
drugs accounted for more than those
caused by heroin and concave and cocaine
combined
in addition
addiction is an extremely stigmatized
medical condition so even within the
medical community
the opinion that opioid misuse is a flaw
in a person's moral character is quite
prevalent despite the fact that research
recent evidence shows that it behaves
like a chronic and remitting disease
perhaps unsurprisingly then people are
turning on mass online for help with
addiction so forum 77 second from the
bottom here is our data set
and it's the largest community on med
health which says something in and of
itself we have about three quarter of a
million posts here but as you can see
even larger communities exist online
and these are just quick summary
statistics that we gathered by hand this
is not an exhaustive list
i'm going to give a quick overview of
the important points of addiction that
are that are useful for our work going
forward so what are prescription opioids
i'm sure everyone's heard of oxycodone
vicodin hydrocodone these are
painkillers they're very effective and
they're also highly addictive
a subclass of these are called opioid
replacement therapy opioids methadone
suboxone and buprenorphine they're also
prescription opioids meaning they're
also painkillers and they're also
addictive however they're longer lasting
and they're less euphoric meaning that
they're sometimes administered under the
supervision of a medical expert
as a replacement therapy for a more
addictive drug
so what happens when you stop taking
opioids you go through withdrawal
which is quite a painful process it's
compared to severe influenza and the
duration of withdrawal depends on the
drug that the user is taking the dosage
of the drug physiological factors
but in the literature measures it to be
approximately 7 to 10 days if you go
cold turkey which means you stop taking
all your drugs or 20 to 35 days in the
case of a taper which means you take
smaller and smaller doses of the drug
until you stop taking it
and so when does somebody recover well
the term recovery is very contentious
there is a lack of agreement within the
medical profession
as to whether you actually recover from
addiction or not and this view is held
over in groups like alcoholics anonymous
and narcotics anonymous instead it's
thought that you're always recovering so
we use the term recovering in our work
and finally relapse the use of drugs
after withdrawing or recovering is
common estimated to happen in some 81 to
91 percent of users
so i'll now talk about drugs of choice
in which we try to identify what
substances people on forum 77 are using
why analyze this
well it helps us to contextualize the
forum so there are many surveys of drug
using populations out there but they're
almost all executed at point-of-care
facilities such as emergency room
departments or rehabilitation facilities
forum 77 participation is voluntary so
if we find congruence in our population
with these other surveys we might be
able to make epidemiological conclusions
and if we don't we may find that we have
a population here that's currently
flying under the radar
there are also some useful applications
out of being able to identify drugs of
choice we may be able to monitor
the
the popularity of new designer drugs as
they come out on the market
we could also test theories on addiction
such as the gateway hypothesis which
posits the drug use starts with less
addictive drugs like marijuana and
alcohol and moves on to more
harder and illicit substances like
cocaine
and there are potential interface
improvements for example we might be
able to match users who have the same
drug of choice
privacy considerations of course
so a drug of choice is any substance
that the user indicates she was or is
addicted to and this is again a
context-sensitive problem so in this
sentence this user's drug of choice is
suboxone because she's currently
tapering off it
in this sentence the user's drug of
choice is vicodin i'm quitting a 10-year
vik habit suboxone is being used as a
replacement treatment later on if this
user were to return to the forum and
start tapering off suboxone then
suboxone would also become a drug of
choice
and these are usually mentioned in
people's initiating posts
so to automate the extraction of drugs
of choice we follow a process similar to
the one that we adopted in adept except
that we label the data ourselves instead
of crowdsourcing the labeling and again
a crf classifier trained on our label
data does well at identifying drugs of
choice mentioned in initiating posts
applying our classifier to the entire
forum 777 data set then
allows us to derive the drug of choice
distribution over the population
we compare this to other prevalent
surveys on substance use and what we
find is that forum 77 is distinct from
typically surveyed populations in terms
of abuse substances so these users are
predominantly struggling with
prescription opioid abuse however the
more traditionally abused substances
alcohol marijuana and cocaine which are
the three most prevalent substances on
the other forums are quite absent in our
community
we can also look at drug trends on the
forum over time and for simplicity we
only show the six most popular opioids
here we see these top two lines
hydrocodone and oxycodone decline
slightly over time and it appears that
suboxone and methadone our replacement
treatment opioids
the pink and yellow lines here
may increase a little bit
to make it easier to see we can
combine these together so now the orange
line represents opioid replacement
therapy opioids the green line
represents all other opioids and heroin
is the purple line on the bottom
so there is a slight decrease in the use
of our other prescription opioids and a
slight increase in your t opioids now
we'd have to do a lot more work to tie
these to actual trends in the real
population but
there are correlations or corroborations
for example samsa's nsats report which
looks at methadone and buprenorphine
prescriptions has cited a steady
increase in buprenorphine prescription
issuing since about 2008
and recent work finds that as
prescription opioids like oxycodone
become harder
to tamper with and acquire on the black
market people switch over to heroin
because it's actually easier to acquire
to summarize
in reading this data we discover that
about half of initiating posts mention
drugs of choice
and we can use hand annotated data to
train a conditional random field
classifier to identify these
automatically finally applying our
classifier to our entire data set we
find that our population is very
distinct from other survey drug using
populations and there's a possibility
that it reflects real world substance
use trends
next we move on to the topic of purpose
in which we address the question of why
people participate in forum 77
and why might we want to do this
this gives us insight into how forum 77
actually supports his users so prior
work does show that emotional and
informational support seeking drive
online health community participation
however
we want to go beyond this what kind of
support and how is this specific to the
topic of addiction
in addition to understanding users
motivations for participation uh the
answering this question will help us
drive future analyses as we said you
really need to understand why people are
authoring this text in order to leverage
it to get insights
and there are some compelling potential
applications such as highlighting
deficiencies in traditional treatment
options
so what are people compensating for on
the forum and exposing key areas for
interface improvement
to investigate users reasons for
initiating posts we first conduct a
thematic analysis over a sample of
initiating posts and i'll quickly go
through the process that we used so
based on our existing knowledge of the
data set we first derived a schema that
we felt appropriately described it
we then consulted with an addiction
specialist
and took a sample of data from our data
set
split it between two annotators and then
compared the overlapping labels in an
error analysis based on the results we
refined our schema and repeated this
process until we arrived at a schema
that produced consistent labels
congruent with prior work we did find
that emotional and
that informational and emotional support
seeking do drive participation on forum
77.
with informational support seeking
however
the majority of content regards the
topic of withdrawal it's actually quite
unusual to find an informational request
that does not deal with withdrawal
and in the emotional category we had a
surprise so
we did find support seeking and support
giving which is what we expected but the
most prevalent label in this category
and actually in the entire schema is
this thing called the update post
and what is an update post an update
post is exactly what it sounds like it's
a log-like report of the user's current
status and it makes no explicit request
for feedback this is a pretty typical
example of an update post i was used to
taking eight to ten oxycodones a day i
haven't taken any of them since friday
but i took one oxy 40 milligrams
saturday and one on sunday morning it's
been almost 24 hours not too bad so far
but i'm sure there's more to come
so given the prevalence of update posts
we were able to tr to train two
classifiers our first a logistic
regression classifier distinguishes
informational from emotional posts and
our second distinguishes update from
non-update posts
then of course we analyze the result of
applying these classifiers to the
entirety of our data set
we analyze a number of features
including thread lifespan which is the
number of days between the day when it
was created and the last post
one of the first things we discover is
that informational threads have longer
life spans but fewer respondents
so
why is this well a casual analysis
suggests that what happens is that these
threads are easily recycled recycled by
other users so newer users will come and
read through posts on the forum and
they'll find a thread that relates to
them
they'll then reply to it in order to
revive it
it may be that users feel that they're
capitalizing on the work that others
have already done in terms of explaining
a condition or set of symptoms in terms
of gathering information
or in terms of cultivating a collection
of people who already care about this
issue so it may be that this is user's
way of not reinventing the wheel
and while examining informational posts
we stumbled upon an informational
artifact on forum 77 called thomas's
recipe which turned out to give some
interesting insight into the nature of
information generation and sharing on
the forum
so thomas's recipe is a detailed
schedule for medication-managed opioid
withdrawal
and it actually originated on med help
around 2000 and it's extremely prevalent
on the forum it's very popular and it's
gone beyond med help if you google it
you'll get adwords sponsors for vitamin
supplements to help with
opioid withdrawals
so here's an example of thomas's recipe
from 2000 and i don't put this up here
for you to read but to compare
structurally to the version that was
posted in 2006
there are quite a lot of changes
number one we have a much longer
disclaimer in the new version
number two the ingredient list has
become substantially more organized it's
even enumerated
number three the instructions have
become much more detailed and if you
actually read through them they've
become more more applicable to a general
audience so
in the 2000 version the recommended
dosage of l-tyrosine is 4 000 milligrams
in the 2006 version it's recommended
that you start with two thousand
milligrams and then adjust accordingly
so why is this interesting
it's interesting because these changes
do not evidence a single person tweaking
a recipe they demonstrate a
collaborative influence of a larger
community and so form 77 is more than an
information repository some users at
least actually use it to collaborate on
treatments that are effective and it is
effective we checked with our addiction
specialist she said this is pretty much
what she would recommend to a patient
but that she hadn't thought of the
l-tyrosine and that that was maybe a
good idea
our other classifier is able to
distinguish update from non-update posts
an analysis of the output shows that
update posts actually have much shorter
life spans but slightly more responses
than other posts so
the fact that they get similar levels of
responses is interesting because there's
no explicit request for feedback this
implies that this request is implicit
and expected
but the shorter lifespan of the update
post ties into another result which is
that the time that it elapses between
success
between successive update posts is quite
short
so this shows the transition graph
between the update state and a
non-update state
here we see that consecutive update
posts have on average four and a half
days between them which is certainly the
shortest time elapsed between any two
phases
so one explanation is that when users
start posting updates they do so in
quick succession posting the next one
kills the lifespan of the old one
and taken together it's possible that in
many cases
issuing update posts is a mechanism of
maintaining momentum and community
support during detoxification attempts
but possibly the most interesting thing
about updates is their prevalence this
indicates that users derive high utility
out of issuing update posts
so what are people valuing here so
anecdotally we think that one thing that
users value is simply being witnessed
right um
this could be a self-enforcement
mechanism to stay on a withdrawal
schedule or to prevent relapse but we do
see users exhibiting a great deal of
shame when they relapse and they don't
want to come back to the community
before they've started another detox
attempt but there's also a clear value
in documentation and we see users
reflecting on their update posts in the
past so both for inspiration to progress
if they've relapsed or as a way of
generating a sense of self-efficacy if
they've successfully withdrawn they also
use this as data so we've seen users go
back and say well i checked my post and
last time it took me 19 days so maybe if
i try this this time it'll take me 15
days to to detox
other users also value people's update
posts they read through them as a way of
getting a sense of what lies ahead
so to summarize our close reading in
this case comprised of thematic analysis
in which we elucidated categories
describing users reasons for
participating in it in forum 77.
congruent with prior work we found that
emotional and informational support
seeking drive
drive participation but we also found
that most informational posts pertain
explicitly to the topic of withdrawal
and that the most prevalent emotional
post is the update
because the update post is so prevalent
we're able to train two classifiers they
distinguish emotional from informational
posts and update from non-update posts
and through applying them we get some
insight into what users value about
participating in the forum
they also use it for collaborative
treatment development they value having
an audience and they value it as a
mechanism for public documentation
finally in our last project on forum 77
we investigate
the phase of addiction
what do i mean by this
so
everyone has heard of this thing called
the cycle of abuse but what does it
actually mean
it turns out that there is not a
well-established
definition or agreed upon cycle of abuse
right and moreover to the best of our
knowledge there have been no attempts to
quantify it we have no idea for example
how many times people relapse on average
before achieving some sort of sustained
recovery and
for example we don't know how long
people tend to use for after they
relapse before they try to quit again
so in this project we seek to define and
quantity this and quantify the cycle of
abuse as it manifests on forum 77 and
this gives us crucial insight into the
role that forum 77 plays in the process
of addiction recovery it's also as far
as we know the first attempt to quantify
a cycle of abuse in any sort of data set
again we conduct a thematic analysis
similar to our purpose project
over-initiating posts in order to derive
a schema describing users phases
for those familiar with the
transtheoretic model of behavior change
i have the labels here on the left but
i'm going to focus on the on the column
form 77 label which is uh which are the
labels that emerged in our thematic
analysis
we can see that a variety of phases
manifest on forum 77 from use of
substances to intention to quit to
planning to quit
there's a lot of cessation attempts
being able to tell whether users are
tapering or going cold turkey is a
little more rare and then there are also
a lot of users here who are currently
recovering
now although this level of detail is
interesting these categories are too
fine-grained for the computational
models that we currently have so
accordingly we collapse them into three
main classes
using when someone is using drugs prior
to a cessation attempt withdrawing when
someone is currently trying to quit
and recovering
when someone has overcome the acute
withdrawal symptoms and is no longer
detoxing from a substance
now there were two things about this
rubric that caused us to reconsider our
unit of analysis from the post to a
sequence
so the first is the low prevalence of
relapse labels here it turns out that
while relapse is very very common users
don't come to the forum and say guys i
relapse and i'm using again actually
they're more likely to come back after
they've started another cessation
attempt perhaps in an attempt to
generate social capital again on the
forum that they feel that they've lost
the other thing is the high prevalence
of na posts these are posts for which we
just can't tell what phase the user is
in
that's not very useful so
looking at sequences actually can
eliminate both of these cases so
imagine that each circle here is a day
in a user's tenure and it's red if
they're using on that day
yellow if they're withdrawing green if
they're recovering and blank if they
don't post on the forum
imagine that we pulled this post out for
our sample
it's pretty hard to tell what phase this
guy's in he's just being social
however
if we look at the post surrounding this
post it's quite clear that he's in the
middle of a cessation attempt and so
we can basically propagate that label
through here
we can also see relapses easily on
sequences
so
here's a relapse
this user left
in a state of recovering and has
returned and they're withdrawing that
means that they used again but they
didn't come back to the forum when they
did it
so to acquire a sample of labeled
sequence data we restrict our sample to
users who've initiated at least five
posts so that we can get a sequence and
then we randomly sample 200 users from
this group and all of their initiating
posts
two annotators then labeled this by hand
and resolved disagreements
through through discussion and
consultation with the rubric
with our labeled data set then we can
start to look at how features differ
across these different categories so the
phases of addiction in real life
correlate with this distinct
psychological and physiological states
so are these mirrored in people's online
contributions and behavior
and to do this we look at a number of
features across our hand labeled data
set we look at behavioral features which
describe what kinds of contributions
people made were they initiating posts
responses self responses we looked at
how long it was since they last
initiated any of these kinds of activity
and we look at this over three time
windows globally
locally over the last five days and
currently within the last 24 hours
we also look at content features the
linguistic inquiry and word count index
has a number of linguistically relevant
features over text
we also use a feature that we call the
number of days clean mentioned so this
is when someone says hey guys i've been
clean for 10 days or i've been off
roxies for 10 months
and we also include a more relaxed
version of this feature which is the
number of days mentioned without the
word clean or off or so forth this is
because users who are often withdrawing
say hooray day four day five but they
don't specifically say the words clean
or off
and our goals here are twofold one to
characterize people's behavior through
these different phases but two to
identify features that will be useful
for classifier training later on
so using
is characterized by long absences from
the forum these people are not very
active and
this may account for the slightly longer
post length maybe they need to catch
other users up with what they've been
doing since they were gone
they had an unusually high value for our
feature measuring how many days clean
they mentioned right and this didn't
really make sense so we went back to the
data to examine why this happened it
turns out in these cases users are often
lamenting clean time that they lost so
they will say something like if i hadn't
relapsed i would have had nine months
today
or something like that
and perhaps unsurprisingly they also
demonstrate the lowest levels of
positive affect this is mirrored in
response posts to using responses
withdrawing users on the other hand are
highly active users on the form and
especially in the region of initiating
posts and responding to those posts that
they initiate
they have the fewest days mentioned
which makes sense because they're saying
things like it's day five it's day six
and they have more language about
feeling and biological processes now
this reflects the fact that withdrawal
is physically an uncomfortable
experience
now recovering users are also extremely
active but
whereas withdrawing users were about
initiating posts recovering users are
about responding to other people's posts
they also have the highest levels of
positive affect the lowest levels of
anxiety
and we observe a very prevalent number
of exclamation marks
in responses to post-issue it issued by
people who are recovering and they're
just getting positive feedback and
congratulations from other forum members
so using these features amongst others
and our fully labeled hand a fully hand
labeled user sequence data we train a
crf classifier that is able to annotate
phase sequences
reasonably accurately so compared to a
baseline f1 score of 20
68 performance is not bad it's good
enough to examine some aggregate trends
it's probably not good enough to examine
an individual's fine-grained sequence
over time
so applying our classifier to our entire
sample of users we can then start to
look at transition probabilities so this
transition matrix shows conditional
probabilities from a source state
represented by a row to a target state
represented by a column so for example
people who are using are 70
likely to be using when they next post
25 likely to be uh withdrawing and five
percent likely to be recovering
and what we see here is this strong
diagonal shows that people post
consecutively in the same state that's
what we expected and we also see that
the progressive edges which is the top
right half of this matrix are more
prevalent than regressive edges which is
the bottom left half
we can also use our crf annotated
sequences to examine face length
distributions so here we see that users
actually don't stay in using for too
long on the forum probably because they
get a lot of encouragement to either
start a cessation
attempt or they leave
the window for withdrawing is slightly
smaller and note how well this aligns
with what the addiction literature
states is the expected window of
withdrawal
7 to 35 days
people who withdraw faster than that
likely relapse and then recovery is the
longest lasting state and note here on
the right
there's a long tale suggesting that a
great number of users on the forum have
achieved some kind of sustained
abstinence
recovery and relapse are important
events in addiction and we can use our
crf labeled sequences to identify them
to identify whether a user relapses
during her tenure on forum 77
we search for regressive sequence
patterns so for example any sequence
where a user goes from recovering to
using or withdrawing
from with from withdrawing to using and
any sequence in which a user goes from
withdrawing is absent for 45 or more
days and withdraws again and the reason
why we use this last sequence is because
it's unlikely that someone would be
withdrawing for so long without
participating on the forum
extracting these patterns were able to
identify whether a user relapsed in
their tenure at least once quite well
and then we also investigate what a
user's state was when she last posted on
the forum so the very last post of her
tenure was the user recovering or not
and here we're just looking for
sequences that either end in recovering
versus ending either in using or
withdrawing
and applying this search over our over
our sequences we're able to identify
this quite accurately too
so extracting these patterns over our
annotated sample we can then examine
this in aggregate so this chart
visualizes user progressions through
addiction during their tenure on forum
77. on the left we have the breakdown in
distribution and what state people come
into the forum whether or not they
relapse and the state they're in in
their last post
so
most users start off using a good number
start off with drawing and we see here
that almost half of them relapse during
their tenure
but despite this
looks like recovery is a favorable
prognosis for almost anyone so
one question we might ask is whether
relapsing hurts your chances of ending
your tenure in recovery
so yes relapsed users are less likely to
end in a state of recovery they have
about a 44 chance of doing so rather
than a 53 chance however
recovering is still the most likely
outcome regardless of whether you
relapse or not
now is this good
it's hard to tell because very little
work in addiction actually investigates
self-detoxification
if we interpret this as a 46
success rate over a user's final detox
attempt then this is an improvement of
literature reported success rates
however we're comparing across very
different study designs so we should
take that as suggestive only
finally
we might want to know what gets a person
to recovering is there something
different about the users who end their
tenure in a state of recovering
it turns out that users who are
recovering
during the time of the last post behave
significantly differently on the forum
during the times that they're using and
withdrawing
most notably they're much more engaged
in the forum they're much more
frequently participating and they
respond much more to other users
it's hard to tell whether this is causal
but this does resonate with literature
and alcoholics anonymous which shows
that increased participation and
engagement with the group corresponds
with a higher likelihood of achieving
sustained sobriety
so to summarize through a thematic
analysis over initiating posts we
uncover three main categories describing
the phases of addiction
using
withdrawing and recovering
analyzing behavioral and content
features of posts in each of these
phases show that user behavior is quite
distinct across the states
and we're able to train a crf classifier
using these features and our label data
to extract to to sorry to annotate phase
sequences from which we can extract
important events relapse and recovery
and finally analyzing these sequences we
find that while relapse is common
recovery is likely and correlates with
hype participation
to conclude i'll first reiterate the
contributions of this work and then i'll
finally go over some important areas for
future work that build on what i've
presented here today
our first contribution
is methods for automatically extracting
medically relevant data from pat
we explored crowdsourcing medical term
annotation as an alternative to getting
medical experts to annotate these terms
we found that this was feasible but not
for all types of tasks
and that there's a trade-off in task
design versus labeling the data yourself
we leveraged thematic analyses to build
content schemas over more abstract or
hidden data contained in pat and we show
how these are both contributions in and
of them themselves for example
describing the cycle of addiction and
they're also useful as annotation
rubrics for hand labeling data
building on the addiction literature we
employ a detailed feature analysis to
determine how users behavior changes
as they move through the phases of
addiction
in the real world correlate with their
behavior online
and ultimately we were able to train
classifiers that automatically extract a
variety of medically relevant data from
pat including medical terms drugs of
choice the purpose of participation and
the phase of addiction
our second contribution is insights
derived from these extracted data
as i mentioned these can be medically
relevant for example
we found that forum 77 is distinct from
other survey drug using populations this
means that studying it may actually
reveal something interesting that we
currently aren't able to observe through
existing surveys
another interesting finding is that
users actively collaborate on treatments
this might be an interesting application
crowdsourcing treatment development
other insights stand as contributions
relevant to the cscw and hci communities
for example we found that users value
being witnessed and documenting their
journey through the process of addiction
but we also have compelling evidence
suggesting that participating in forum
77 plays an important role in aiding the
withdrawal process
certain users are most likely to be
recovering
certainly users are most likely to be
recovering by the time that they leave
although
we do need to remember that our data are
censored we don't know what happens to
them after they leave the forum however
it may be helpful just to have a tool
and to enhance a tool that will help you
withdraw successfully
so in concert our contributions both
underscore pat's latent value for
illuminating poorly understood or
clandestine medical topics and offer
viable methods that dramatically improve
our ability to realize this value
there's several areas of future work
that uh that could build on what i've
presented here today
one is supporting the methodological
process that we exposed so
for example um
it would be really helpful to have
interface support for thematic analysis
currently this does not exist but
thematic analysis is used a lot to
derive these deep understandings of
qualitative data
it's very hard to track your provenance
to share with other people and creating
tools for these sorts of things would
actually help to standardize the process
make it more accessible to everyone else
the next area is to push for medical
insights to medical discoveries so for
example could we identify new designer
drugs from these data such work would
require intense collaboration with
medical researchers in order to acquire
epidemiological validity
but another thing to look into is does
forum participate form 77 participation
aid long-term recovery we would actually
need to interact with users in real time
and see how forum 77 complements their
other treatment modes in order to
determine this
and finally
our insights suggest a number of ways in
which we might be able to
improve design and support existing
patient author text contribution
interfaces so for example
we could align users with sponsors in
forum 77 to get them to participate more
we could expose data driven withdrawal
information so not only are people
looking for this on the forum they read
very slowly through other people's posts
in order to aggregate this in their
minds
not only are they looking for but it's
also been shown that telling someone the
severity of the symptoms that they're
going to experience with withdrawal
actually result in them being more
likely to complete their withdrawal
process
and finally given that users are
invested in documenting their experience
we could use something like our update
classifier to automatically construct
timelines and enable users to compare
their timelines with other peoples
so to summarize
there are a lot of improvements we could
do on this methodological process from
interface support
on uh thematic analysis
to feature exploration and to extraction
from our insights we could move on to
deriving medical discoveries with the
collaboration of
medical researchers
and we could feedback a lot of the
things we've already developed and use
our insights to improve pat interfaces
and before i take questions
i just want to thank everyone again for
being here especially to those of you
who who traveled and one of the best
things about being at a place like
stanford is the people you get to meet
and learn from and i'd like to
acknowledge some folks who've been
especially influential during my time
here so first of course my advisor jeff
jeff has been an incredible source of
inspiration support and knowledge to me
during my five and a bit years here
jeff's advice and input are always spot
on and generously given but even more
importantly
he's been an exemplary role model to me
so i'm both grateful and proud to have
him as an advisor
of course to my committee uh stu card
michael bernstein chris manning justin
grimmer thank you all for being here um
chris for all your input on the work
we've collaborated with and stu without
your
exceptional
tactical abilities i don't think i'd
have as good deadline meeting skills as
i do today
to my collaborators sonal it's been a
pleasure to work with you and i look
forward to continuing to do so and to
anna lemke who couldn't make it here
today uh but whose enthusiasm about this
work and generosity with her time really
was invaluable in marrying our work with
addiction literature and understanding
that
uh the inevitable margot seltzer who got
me into this whole business in the first
place
and uh to the amazing people i've met in
my time here there are so many of you my
good friends sadindra catherine jonathan
um you're all wonderful last but not
least my husband isa who's been making
me push the envelope a little bit every
day since i met him and uh my mom who
traveled here especially so that she
could finally find out what i've been up
to for the last five years
and i'll take questions
so you found that people who were more
active on the forum during the
withdrawal phase were more likely to
succeed in uh quitting do you know what
that was due to more like if they got
more community support or whether it was
just the act of posting itself that was
legal i mean
i could hypothesize that's also possibly
a selection bias right maybe people who
are more active are just more motivated
to quit or have some sort of
you
know internal drive that makes them more
successful at quitting and maybe the
collaborative support that they get the
community is very supportive so i would
hesitate to say that people don't get a
lot of support unless they're
kind of mean
um
so i don't know it could be that i think
it could be a selection bias so this is
a huge problem in analyzing alcoholics
anonymous and narcotics anonymous and
it's well cited in that literature too
yeah how are you dealing with
people using acronyms and inconsistent
spelling and stuff like that that's
someone else
uh we did a massive amount of entity
resolution which i didn't go over uh
because it it was quite long but we did
most of it manually actually so
we found 58 different ways of spelling
vicodin
and then we actually collaborated a lot
with anna lemke uh who's a psychiatrist
um to resolve a lot of those drugs to
categories so you know like opioids and
sedatives and stuff like that so it was
mostly a manual process and yes i think
you could automate it that would be a
different project
yeah
um so you said that
they post responses i'm wondering what
the nature of those responses were
started a lot of like congratulations on
those people actually like go through
the face together for example let's get
together
that's a really great question like i
would love to know if people sort of go
through the faces together um
i i my guess would be that
my guess is that a lot of people who are
responding and it's supported in the
data are those who've already recovered
so if you look at 12-step programs like
aanna the 12th step is to help other
people recover
um
you know that to maintain your own
sobriety so my guess is that a lot of
the people who do that have already
recovered i don't know if they go
through the phases together um
i lost the second half of your question
though
um
oh
positive reinforcement and encouragement
mostly um
yeah there were some shared experiences
so some it's something that we haven't
analyzed response posts and that's
something we really
would like to do i would like to do a
future work it's interesting um
but
people like to
jump off people's stories and tell their
own narration so they'll take a point
from someone's story and tell something
similar that happened to them there's a
lot of narrative going on there too
yeah
so you started getting at this in future
work but uh so now if you got control of
form 77 for like a month and you got to
have whatever features you'd like what
would you like to add now to help people
recover i think i'd first give them the
data on withdrawal i think that i mean
so you'd have to be careful how you do
this because they don't want to feel
like you're
kind of spying on them right but i think
that
a i think it would be interesting to
interview some of those community
leaders and ask how to introduce
data-driven insights back into the forum
because they really are so they're parts
of the forum that you don't want to
replace like there's value in getting
feedback even if it's a question that's
being asked before people feel connected
but there are other parts that are
inefficient and users find that they're
inefficient and then they'll they'll
start pulling people they'll be like how
many people have successfully tapered
off this versus that and they'll you
know try to get responses and that sort
of thing i think you could make more
accessible and i think
i think patients are really smart enough
to deal with that sort of data and
should have access to it
yeah
that's what i do
uh you were next hey uh fantastic talk
um i thought you motivated it really
well
what
i don't i didn't realize what a huge
public health problem this is
so that's really cool
now i want to ask a very broad high
level question which is
we saw a lot about
drug addiction and how people try to
overcome it in this talk
what about the topic of what causes this
and where this comes from and can we
prevent this from happening in the first
place now i realize that's not been the
focus of your research but is could we
get that in the same
data is there information there do we
know something about that
i think this is quite well addressed in
the addiction literature already um
so
well perhaps not you do have a point so
a lot of people that we read about they
are prescribed pain medication for
legitimate reasons and they get addicted
to it and one type of user that i see
often um
which i just feel that they're in a
catch-22 they do have some chronic pain
condition and they have a choice to be
addicted to the meds or to be in pain
and um
that i think i i don't really know how
how you deal with that um
but i'm not sure this would be the best
data set for
for figuring out how people get addicted
in the first place for figuring out
where people get their drugs from that's
something that sonal and i talked about
a little bit and that you you might be
able to do because people talk about
getting them oh from their
uh
from their friends from their doctors
some
there was even a case where someone was
buying them from his parents because
they were broke and he felt bad and so
they sold him there yeah yeah so you
could get really
you could get a pretty deep answer to
where people get the drugs from which is
also interesting in ameliorating the
problem and plugging you know black
market halls
yeah
yeah um could you possibly bring up the
the graph with um kind of the the start
state versus end statement and the
relapse
section
uh because i noticed in there there's a
very significant proportions of
users that um where their start state is
their end state as well um and so was
was wondering um
kind of of those
users um
what was the the threshold for how long
a user had to be active on the forum to
be included in their data sets or maybe
like
any
users who were just on their very short
period of time right so
uh that's a good point so we didn't have
a time threshold it was a post threshold
so if they'd initiated five or more
posts on the forum and i would
agree with you that it is likely that a
lot of those users who start and end in
the same state they probably just
shorter lived and they actually haven't
left the forum but it's hard to tell if
someone's left because
they might come back you know so that's
a good question yeah something that
would be good to explore
so given that you you're able to observe
their like their
withdrawal plans as well as their
success rates like that effectively
suggests like like um some kind of like
you can come up with like a formula for
like this is the optimum taper off rate
that will maximize your success rate
right um have you tried like
uh have you ever compared that with like
what like a professional would say
well so we did look at thomas's recipe
and take it to
we did look over with anna and and go
through it so
this is one of those cases where i'm not
sure the data is fine-grained enough to
get an absolute answer to your question
so for every person we see
successfully quitting we don't
necessarily know what their tapering
rate was but but sometimes we do we
might be able to extract it but i think
that will be difficult without
demographic data because so much of the
duration depends on physiological
factors like your weight or you know
your gender
yeah
so
like what you might do to actually
improve the quality of the data that's
coming in
um and i'm wondering if you if you've
thought about
insights that might become
available if the data was a little bit
better like if the text was better or if
you had maybe
user provided labels on it on the data
or something like that
i mean something i wanted to do is is a
symptom autocomplete you know so you
know if someone talks about having
restless legs they're probably also
going to have because one thing we have
is incomplete lists of symptoms so
people will only list what they find
severe but sometimes the fact that
something is missing is interesting so
imagine you typed in that oh i have
restless legs and you get a check spot
checkbox or something of other symptoms
that you may or may not have and that
would give us much more detailed and
fine grained data so i think that's one
way in which you can improve it i also
just think by making it more efficient
for users to get the information that
they want you're going to filter out a
lot of the craft that you have to begin
with and then i think your text will
become more relevant with what you're
working with so i think you could get
this sort of virtuous cycle in which you
improve the interface you get baited
better data and so forth
yeah
that was excellent um i'm curious for
the
over the user's life cycle
what was distribution of times that they
relapsed and then also
did some people start in a relapse state
and specifically
mention that like i'm wondering if
people for example geosocial pressure
came to the forum was like oh yeah it's
the third time i've relapsed but they
were forced by such pressure to make new
accounts
so the answer to your first question is
i don't totally know so as i as we saw
for our sequence based crf um we can use
that to find out whether someone
relapsed at least once but it doesn't
necessarily give us an exact count of
how many times people relapsed right
anecdotally it happens often and it's
sometimes ambiguous i mean there are a
lot of half-hearted withdrawal attempts
where people be like oh it's day four
but i took a pill this morning no biggie
you know um
so not sure what's going on there um
the second part of your question
can you just refresh my my memory uh i
was just wondering about people that
start in sort of a real upstairs yes
do they make new accounts yes uh no
they try uh and then people who use the
forum a lot catch them out
they actually share a lot of personal
information with each other so they'll
you'll know things like whether the
person has a husband or kids or a dog or
they might mention what state they live
in and so you
other community members actually hunt
them down and say you are tom 99 aren't
you uh you're deceiving everyone and
it's very negatively perceived yeah
yeah
since you have a way of contacting the
users
and you have also kind of like facts
where are the
patterns that
land them through withdrawal would it be
interesting to maybe like contact them
at that phase when you recognize that
some user is
actually at that point and trying to
bring them back to the forum
so i've wondered
about interventions yes maybe
uh i think it's hard to say i think that
there's a you're walking a very fine
line between privacy and feeling that
you're being observed and actually
helping someone
there's evidence showing an addiction
that intervening at a particular stage
of behavior change doesn't necessarily
help
but there are a lot of different study
designs it's really impossible to get a
conclusive answer there um
i don't know so
i think intervention is an interesting
question i think it needs to be very
delicately handled yeah
i think that's probably
all we have time for
let's thank our speaker